.
EVER.
KEVIN McCARTHY CALLED ON DHS
SECRETARY ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS TO
STEP DOWN FROM MISMANAGEMENT
FROM THE BORDER CRISIS NO BETTER
BORDER BREAK NO INTENTION OF
RESIGNING, THAT'S NOT A
SURPRISE, TEXAS CONGRESSMAN DAN
CRENSHAW ALSO VISITED THE BORDER
YESTERDAY AND DELIVERED A VERY
STRONG MESSAGE TO THE CARTELS IN
A LANG WILL STING.
>>
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
BRIAN CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW
JOINS US NOW.
WHAT BROUGHT TO YOU THE POINT
WHERE YOU HAD TO CALL THEM OUT
AND COULD YOU FULFILL WHAT YOU
SAID YOU WOULD DO AND MAKE THEIR
LIFE HELL?
>> WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO.
LOOK, THEY DECLARED A WAR ON US
A LONG TIME AGO.
I THINK EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
THAT BY NOW.
WE HAVE 80,000 AMERICANS A YEAR
DYING FROM FENTANYL.
THAT'S NOT A DRUG PROBLEM,
THAT'S A POISONING PROBLEM.
ON PURPOSE.
THEY HAVE BEEN AT WAR WITH US
FOR AIL WHO.
THEY FACILITATE THIS THE ENTIRE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
THEY FACILITATE THE WHOLE THING.
TIME WE GO TO WAR WITH THEM AND
TIME WE MAKE THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT COOPERATE WITH US ON
THAT.
LEGISLATION LAST WEEK CALLED
DECLARING WAR ON THE CARTEL'S
ACT.
INCREASE OUR AUTHORITIES
BASICALLY TREAT THEM LIKE
TERRORISTS.
ALLOW SANCTION THOSE THOUGH AID
AND ABET THEM.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M TALKING TO THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
CORRUPT MEXICAN OFFICIALS THAT
AID AND ABET THESE.
THEY HAVE GO AFTER THEM IN A
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE A PARTISAN
ISSUE BY THE WAY.
THIS HAS TO BE A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH CBP LEADING
THE CHARGE ALSO WITH THE D.E.A.,
THE CIA, THE FBI, THE MILITARY.
THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
THIS IS SOME OF THE MOST
WELL-EQUIPPED, WELL-ARMED, MOST
DANGEROUS PEOPLE ON EARTH JUST
SOUTH OF OUR BORDER AND MEXICO
IS AT RISK OF BECOMING A FAILED
NARCO-STATE.
IF WE DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO
THIS RIGHT NOW, IF WE DON'T
ACCEPT THE FACT THAT WE ARE
ALREADY AT WAR THEN WE ARE GOING
TO LOSE IT PRETTY QUICK.
THIS ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO GET
ON BOARD INFURIATING THIS IS NOT
A PARTISAN.
BORDER AND TAKE CARE OF THIS
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
>> Brian: DAN, THEY SAY THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE NO PLAN.
THEY WANT TO CREATE DO THESE
TRICKS AT THE BORDER IS THAT
WHAT WAS GOING ON YESTERDAY
KEVIN McCARTHY THESE TRICKS AT
THE BORDER?
>> I'M DISGUSTED BY EVERYTHING
THAT COMES OUT OF THE PRESS
SECRETARY'S MOUTH THESE DAYS.
OF COURSE WE HAVE PLAN.
I TOLD YOU ABOUT THE BILL I HAVE
INTRODUCED.
AND INTRODUCED OTHER BILLS FIX
THE ASYLUM PROCESS.
DO THINGS THAT ACTUALLY CREATE
THE PROBLEM.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE OUR PLAN
WOULD BE, HAVING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT DO ITS JOB AND
ESTABLISH FLIGHT ROUTES WITH
THESE OTHER COUNTRIE